um for the second time in a month uh you
probably had to stand up in front of
your teammates or have some difficult
conversations with teammates uh about
something that just
might be gold basically that that hit um
what's that process been like and what's
your emotions been like over the last
couple of days yeah um
yeah uh
my emotions have been um
on a roller coaster so to speak this
year you know and um
my my heart goes out
so much
try and say it with a straight face
because i've already been emotional
about every bit of this
but to the family
to all the families involved
you know you never want no one ever
wants to see this whether it's a
football player or not
you never want to see something like
this happen and uh
you know it broke it broke my wife and
i's heart you know honestly and
you know we talked about it a little bit
but i can only talk about it so much you
know
but at the same time
whether it's fair or not
i have to compartmentalize and i have a
job to do these are two totally
different
situations some similar emotions some
very different emotions um
uh but
the message has to stay the same you
don't honestly i don't want it to right
now if i'm selfish
i don't want it to be i want to
say a lot of different things but
we have a game this week and i've got a
job to do and so do the the guys in that
locker room and
from that aspect from a football aspect
i hate to talk about both in the same
thing but it's weird and that's what
we're doing right
from a football aspect every man in that
locker room kind of feels the same way
and
but we have work to do we had to come
out and practice we had film study
monday and tuesday you know like we have
you know all of these things that we
still have to do right and so
i don't know the right way to handle it
um but i'm doing my best
you've made a career
out of
game planning against difficult
situations
but inexplicable tragedy doesn't really
have
much of a game plan
how helpless is that as a guy who wants
to control
yeah um
you know just for me personally me my in
my own life um
you know
i i've experienced loss and so i i know
that feeling and so my heart first goes
to the families that are involved okay
you know
when there's things that happen in life
for all of us that we don't have control
over and
you wish you did i have a thousand
questions i wish i could ask
you know but
i don't get those opportunities you know
uh you know i i don't understand
everything and why certain things happen
um and i and i've i just forever have
relied
on the foundation of who i am is my
faith and i'm gonna stand on that when
it's hard and i'm gonna stand on it when
it's easy and and that's just who i'm
gonna be
when i can control something and when i
can't
and so when it comes to this situation
you know there's so many things out of
our control but then i do sit back and i
think
you know was there something did i you
know did i not
did i not let him know that he really
could i'd be there for him at 3am you
know that you know i i'm i want to be
better you know i think
i really look at everything in my life
as a learning experience could i have
been better you know to help or
something you know i just um
i just wish i i just wish i
i could have done something you know i
look at it that way could i have done
anything to help you know even when it
seems impossible is there any little
thing i could have done better you know
and um i know it's a crazy thing to even
think or say but i'm always looking at
trying to be a better person
for you what was yesterday like for you
just kind of when the news started
trickling out that was emotional um
for you know when i even when i see
things it's weird when you have kids
how uh how things can be a little bit
more emotional than they used to be
that's for sure
now that i have four you know of my own
um
instantly my thoughts go to certain
places and uh
and things like that and
it's hard it's not easy i can promise
you that it is a it's a tragic thing um
and again
i don't
i know as
most of you probably even know more than
me you know but i know as much as i've
seen or heard
but
i i really don't know the right thing to
say to somebody i
i try my best to be there in support of
someone or be there for anybody if i
knew who to be there for and all those
things but
you know my my thoughts i guess
selfishly went to my own kids in my own
family and
you know how do i you know how do i
teach them you know
you know how do i how do i take this and
turn it to a learning experience you
know
and things like that
because no one
including henry wanted this to happen
how would you characterize the mental
state of this team right now
uh
from a football aspect i mean we're
ready to go you know we had a great
practice
you know we're we're
we're dealing with a lot of things this
year that's for sure um a lot of guys
just what a crazy year you know i heard
that a couple times you know
i heard
goodness gracious you know like man you
know just like
can we please nothing else you know um
not for our own sake but just for the
sake of everyone else you know just for
everyone involved you know
um but from a football aspect from a
competitive aspect we're we're ready to
play football there's no doubt about
that
you know we know where we're at
from that from that standpoint and we
know what we have
to do we know that this was the time of
year where we hit a lull a couple times
you know and we can't let that happen no
matter what's going on man me and
911 say it to each other everybody every
day nobody cares you know at the other
day nobody cares what we're going
through how your body feels nobody cares
we gotta we gotta do our job
and uh we we emphasized that to each
other again today you know hey i got
your back you got mine nobody cares man
we got to go and before practice during
practice after practice you know we're
always just trying to push whoever's
listening that
is it fair no
because i want to
have emotions about things i want to
think about things as a human being you
know
you know football is secondary when
something like this happens you know
this is we're talking about lives and
you know a lot of a lot of different
lives in a lot of different situations
but
for us from a football aspect our
mindset is we are we're going to be
ready to play that's for sure
just by how tragic this all is uh to
kind of turn the negatives of odds of
saying the phrase
those guys are going to have to step up
in a situation like this are you really
excited to see what kind of the weapons
is going to bring out of them oh
absolutely um yeah i'm very excited you
know i think i've always thought the
world of isaiah you know i've always
thought the world of hunter you know
i've thought the world of those guys and
um
obviously hunter has gotten a lot of
opportunities um
now
zay and our other guys they're gonna get
a lot more opportunities and i am
excited for them you know because they
work so hard you know i
i think a common theme of when i've
talked about zay is how hard he works
and i think we've seen you guys have
seen at training camp and how
just the relentlessness he practices
with and it's it's literally every day
he's the hardest practicing person i've
ever seen in my life um
and uh i i am excited for him like when
he's made plays in the games i get you
guys here i talk about him after the
game i'm just so excited for him um now
he has a very big role
the roles change you know in the nfl
quickly and his role has changed just
along with some other guys roles are
gonna change
uh but that it's still whatever your
role is do it to the best of your
ability and you know it's gotta be like
nothing ever happened you know when
darren waller
goes out and he says i can't play well
foster more has to step up and be the
starting tight end he has a big day you
know and
it wasn't just because it just happened
it was because he's prepared for that
moment and i think
zay and all these guys have prepared for
this moment
before the buy
we had asked about is it a good time for
the buy when you're playing so well and
everything else and you said we haven't
really had a chance to process with john
and everything else yeah now
you don't you still haven't really i
guess had that chance and now something
else happened so like
how does
how does that process kind of go now you
got to be in the field in a couple days
yeah i just don't get that chance you
know um
again life's not fair it's good good
learning experience for my boys and my
my little girl that i'll teach them life
life is tough sometimes and it's not
fair and it doesn't care sometimes
but you're going to hold true to what
you believe and you're going to hold
true to who you are and you're going to
be that person whether it's easier or
it's not
and that's the standard that i'm going
to hold my children to and that's the
standard i hold myself to if i can't do
it then how can i tell them to do it you
know and so
it's hard sometimes life sucks
and it's hard but
i can assure you life is a lot more
difficult for some
for some other people uh today than it
is for me
you guys have gone through a lot of
changes to offense this year between
injuries and play card change and
obviously losing a big pc offensive runs
what's kind of the key to u.s offense
and overall unit staying on track before
how do you you know practically put that
together i think one word i can think of
as selfless um
that
our our superstar player
and our tight end is the most selfless
player
on our team you know and
and when your best players your most
selfless player everyone has to fall in
line you know who can who can argue
about not getting targets and if his
targets go from
20 to four one day you know he's
he's the biggest cheerleader on the
sideline the game that he's not playing
you know he's the most supportive you
know and
i i would say that just being selfless
um and being prepared you know uh what i
love about you know when when gru was
here what i love about uh coach pasacha
and what i love about mr mayok is
is
if you don't work hard you just won't be
here you know it and i love that because
i don't i don't have to pull teeth every
day you know i know that if they don't
work hard they've shown me over time
that you're just you're just not going
to be here if you're not going to be
ready and prepared when it's your time
and uh you know for these guys
for our offense um
the word i just say is selfless they zay
jones is the hardest practicing guy ever
knowing that henry ruggs was going to
take every rep until he was tired you
know um and now because he played so
hard because he practiced so hard and we
all believed in him
what a great opportunity you know and an
exciting moment for him and
just some other guys that i won't name
because they may have to play for us and
have roles too
but uh they have prepared for this
moment and that makes me excited like i
said for those guys because i know
they're ready
this team has a real wii and not a me
mentality
do you think that's part of the reason
for the resiliency in dealing with john
and your optimism moving forward yeah i
mean
anyone who's covered our team for
a long time um some more than others you
know uh i've always been glass half full
you know and
even when i didn't want to be you know
uh maybe a few times you can catch me in
a bad mood but i've tried my best to
stay positive you know and
and and just always be be someone that
some little kid that's a raider fan
could look to and be like
man that's he's going through a tough
time but
man how does he have joy like that you
know how can he still be a good teammate
you know how can he
you know those are those honestly those
are the these are the things i'm going
to teach my children way above like this
is how you throw a slant you know like i
i don't even teach them some of them
naturally just do it but
i will teach them lessons on character
and things like that
and that's what our team is is built a
group of men
that i've said the word unity a lot you
know you said we you know we you know
coach passage always says we fence you
know all these different things right
and we have just a group of unselfish
people that
i said all the time it would just be so
great to go on a run with this group of
guys it really would you know because no
one cares who gets the glory you know uh
we've thrown the ball for a lot of yards
and that's awesome josh is the first one
high fiving me on the sideline like keep
going keep going because he knows it's
going to open him up and as soon as he's
rolling i'm like bro keep going keep
going so i know the play action and all
that's going to be there so
when you have guys that are good
football players but even better people
you end up with a good football team
that doesn't guarantee you're going to
win but it does make coming to work a
lot more fun have you had a chance to
talk to henry again
no um honestly with with what we were
told i just didn't know if we were able
to um
haven't reached out i will always
be here for him
um that won't change and i'll prove that
over the course of time to him um not to
anybody else
but
he needs people to love him right now
he's probably
feeling a certain type of way about
himself right now and he needs to be
loved and uh
if no one else will do it i'll do it two
more guys
you were you mentioned a little bit ago
you know this time of the year has been
the time you guys have had some lulls
you've had some lows after buy weeks in
the past two yeah do you guys discuss
that you ignore it and just say hey
that's that's a mental is it is there an
explanation for it i guess how you kind
of approach those things i think uh so
we have player council meeting uh with
um
i don't know the exact number 15 guys of
our leaders on the team with coach
pasacha and it was addressed
that this is a certain time of year
where things happen you know and certain
teams go this way and other teams go
this way
and we have to stay on top of everything
that we believe and our effort and
practice and our film study in the in
the things that we don't talk about
that's that we believe separate us we
have to stay on top of that
and we have to hold each other to that
standard um because if we don't then
we'll be one one of those teams that
goes the wrong way and we don't want to
be that and uh nothing's promised if you
just do things the right way you know
but it sure does help if
we can if we can look at things in the
past and say well i think this will help
us be better
as long as you're trying to get better
we're all going to try that way and
hopefully we can stay
stay stay stay winning football games
and stay efficient on offense and
stopping people on defense that's what
it's about
derek you touched on it earlier but
between compartmentalizing things and
being human how tough is this just to
navigate as you know the the quarterback
facing the franchise team leader it's
hard uh
if i'd be lying to you if i was like oh
it's easy you know i i don't think that
at all it's not i've always been honest
with you guys um
and it's it's yeah it's not it's not
easy uh
you know because
i love people
um i care deeply about people
um
i mean there's people in this room that
know that for sure that i've had
conversations with sitting at a table
because i just care about people you
know
and
this one hurts you know because
again
it really affects
some families and and affected some
lives you know and uh that that hurts me
hurts my heart
um because i know that there's pain i
know their shame i know that there's uh
anger probably uh all those feelings
that uh that no one ever wants to feel
or have towards them i know that it's
all there and that's hard
you know when you feel everything's
coming crashing on you i've felt i've
had those feelings you know and having
people to love you and support you
is what is what helps the most you know
you can't do it alone um and so
it is it's not easy you know being a
quarterback and being human you know uh
you know i wish
i wish there was a
a certain way or someone to tell me this
is exactly how you do it cause it'd be a
lot easier um i think i got a good grasp
on how to handle it but it doesn't make
it easy to do you know um doing things
the right way is it sounds easy but it's
not easy to do right and so i'm trying
trying my best
and again maybe maybe some time sometime
in the off season i'll have time to
think
think about all this uh
i will tell you i walked by and i you
know saw henry's locker today and for
whatever reason that got me you know
like
like he's not
he's not going to be there you know
not because he's fast not because of
what he could do for me but because of
the person that he is and because i love
him and uh
um
he i mean he literally texted me you
know at midnight a golf swing you know
hit me and hunter you know um how's my
swing look you guys need to help me
you know
and uh
bro um just
just seeing that and then getting the
news when we woke up i just
like i mean i don't even know how am i
supposed to handle that you know how am
i supposed to react and i'm trying my
best doing my best
but i knew but i do know that god is
good
and i'm going to believe that for my
entire life and i'm going to believe
that he can change
uh situations and do things that you
know we just we just can't comprehend
sometimes and i'm going to continue to
believe that my kids will believe that
and we'll keep preaching that even when
people don't like it all right thank you
guys thank you guys